I am ready to say and I know that there
are people including friends of mine who
are going to be upset with me for saying
this it's time for MSNBC to fire joy and
read and I don't mean just because her
show is terrible I mean because at this
point she simply has no credibility
based on the bogus explanations she has
given for some horrible blog posts that
have been uncovered from her web site in
the past homophobic blog posts
conspiratorial blog posts and I don't
know that I've ever even mentioned joy
read on the program before she's an
MSNBC host she really epitomizes the
corporate establishment wing of the
Democratic Party period I've never seen
her say anything interesting ever but
her presence at MSNBC now has actually
become proactively embarrassing since
she started claiming that her homophobic
blog posts of the past were the result
of someone hacking her web site hacking
for which there has been no evidence
actually took place so let me catch you
up on the story late last year some old
homophobic blog posts of joy Reid
surfaced on social media and in the post
she was calling certain politicians
closeted gay guys she was using gay sex
to mock people she was talking about how
finding gay sex Republic repugnant is
logical genuinely blog posts that were
damaging to the LGBT community and she
immediately said that she thought that
her blog may have been hacked because
she didn't write or didn't remember
writing any of that stuff and of course
totally predictably there was no
evidence that that any of that hacking
actually took place and the hubbub sort
of died down and then somehow last week
when the racist comments from Roseanne
Barr exploded on Twitter I turn MSNBC on
for a few minutes and in they bring joy
and Reid to talk about the inappropriate
and ancient nature of the comments
because I guess she had just hosted some
kind of panel with Valerie Jarrett who
was the target of Roseanne's comments
why on earth would you bring on joy Reid
to talk about what's inappropriate when
she wrote countless inappropriate blog
posts and now it's getting even worse it
has now been revealed that Joanne read
previously promoted a 911 conspiracy
movie co-produced by none other than
Alex Jones in a blog post called the
official story back in two
six in another blog post she said that
it was suspicious that the government
identified the 9/11 plotters so quickly
and then she went on to question why the
buildings fell at all she also suggested
in a post that Ann Coulter might really
be a man which is also just completely
in poor taste and not any kind of
argument whatsoever so MSNBC is
embarrassing itself by not firing her
and I have people who when I tweeted
that it's time to fire her they said
David you can't compare what Roseanne
did to what Jo Ann Reid did Roseanne
said crazy things right now and Jo Ann
Reid said she has changed her views and
doesn't think this stuff anymore that's
fine
but she's been blatantly dishonest in
talking about hacking for a long time
about this I don't think she believes
for one fraction of a second that she
was actually hacked and she's basically
saying you know I did have some views
that I changed my mind on and people
evolved but the blog posts were fake and
I was hacked The Daily Beast has
temporarily suspended her column she's
no longer getting a straight for
equality in media award from a gay
rights group but I believe it is time
for MSNBC to do the right thing and fire
her I don't know if you disagree with me
Pat I have mixed feelings if it was just
about the homophobic blog post that
would be one thing because it was during
the early 2000s when very few people
understood LGBT issues gay marriage was
not the law of the land yet so you know
looking back she could if she was able
to apologize for that I think she would
have been able to weather that storm
same thing when it comes to like 9/11
conspiracy theories at one point I think
up to a third of Americans thought that
the government was responsible for 9/11
so if she just came out and gave a full
apology said that I've evolved on these
issues and I no longer think this way
then I think we would be able to excuse
it but the hacking excuse the amnesia
excuse it's a bridge too far and I think
MSNBC if they don't fire her they should
at least you know have the tone
sensitivity to know that she shouldn't
be talking about like in a Roseanne how
our issue and your thoughts I know this
is going to be polarizing for the
audience if I am wrong tell me
specifically why and it should not
simply be that what Roseanne did is
worse right that's not really an
argument because what I'm laying out
here is
total lack of credibility on this entire
hacking explanation and she just can't
remember and it really doesn't sound
like something she would have written
although yes she did have used before
that she no longer holds if I'm wrong
tell me why I welcome your constructive
criticism I am tolerant of the trolling
that I'm going to get but I actually
welcome the constructive criticism best
place probably Twitter where I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman